patricia dem rhein in sturm deutschland
orkan deutschland wir haben ihnen hier
einmal die sturm stärken aktuell
aufgemalt das ist also der stand jetzt
in der nacht harz lokal schon heftiger
geblasen in einigen regionen
deutschlands vor allen dingen in
norddeutschland an nord aber auch an
ostseeküste und aktuell entwickelt sich
auch sachsen anhalt zu einer solchen
hotspot also dass der aktuelle sturm
stand wir sehen sturm stärken bis zu 8
und 9 hier oben auch an der ostseeküste
das heißt wir sehen auch schon erste
meldungen von ihnen von unseren
zuschauern die sagen mensch ist doch gar
nicht so schlimm ist ein heftiger sturm
aber so schlimm ist es nicht das wird
sich weiterentwickeln das war auch von
allen wetterexperten so angekündigt
diese stürme dieser organe jetzt in
diesen tagen die sind sehr sehr
ausdauernd da werden eben mehrere organe
folgen das wird uns in den nächsten
stunden in den nächsten tagen weiter
begleiten dass der aktuelle stand und
dann gehen wir doch mal durch durch die
nächsten stunden also vielleicht noch
ein bisschen näher dran an deutschland
wir bewegen uns jetzt einmal weiter
durch den heutigen tag rot bedeutet
daneben heftige sturm stärken und
violett sind orkan es wird sich dann am
nachmittag richtung abend erstmal etwas
entspannen auch freitag noch in den
morgenstunden in den vormittagsstunden
und da wird der sturm richtung
nachmittag da sind wir jetzt richtung
abend wieder heftig zu nehmen vor allen
dingen von norden runter nach ganz
deutschland und am samstag dann kommt
das nächste sturmtief rhein in unser
land also das ist eine ganze folge von
orkantiefs die uns erwischen wird in den
nächsten stunden in den nächsten tagen
das ganze wochenende wird das das große
gesprächsthema sein in deutschland der
sturm der orkan der jetzt wo wir alle
aufgewacht sind die ersten schäden
offenlegt wir haben gesehen wo partei
die schwebebahn dort schwer beschädigt
wir haben vielerorts bäume auf autos
natürlich gesehen wir haben den
überspielten überspülten fischmarkt
gesehen und wir wissen dass es an
einigen orten vor allen dingen in
sachsen anhalt im moment besonders
heftig zur sache geht und dort
mittendrin steht hannes rafik aktuell am
brocken dort er hat es tatsächlich noch
auf geschafft auf den brocken davon aber
natürlich ab dass in diesen stunden zu
tun hannes sah kurz einmal aktuell wie
es bei dir aussieht wir sehen die bilder
ja du stehst mitten im auge des sturms
sozusagen
genau also das ist ganz wichtig dass wir
hier mit spezialausrüstung auf dem
gipfel des brockens sind es ist absolut
davon abzuraten das nachzumachen was wir
hier gerade tun das ist wirklich nur
unter professioneller anleitung möglich
und mit professioneller ausrüstung der
wind hat der orkan spritzen von über 150
stundenkilometern der fähigen mann wie
mich nahezu weg ich muss mich hier
wirklich mit aller kraft gegen die wind
wand stimmen der wind macht aus den
winzigen kleinen schneekristallen winzig
kleine geschosse die gegen die augen
prallen dass heißt die sicht wird einem
genommen und der wind kühlt die haut so
massiv innerhalb von wenigen sekunden
aus dass ich also jetzt diese wohl maske
über das gesicht gezogen habe und ich
spreche werden meine lippen eiskalt und
ich wusste das gesicht halten es ist
kein ort an dem man heute die natur
genießen kann sie bringen sich wenn sie
heute hier oben wandern wollen oder in
die natur gehen sich unnötig in gefahr
bleiben sie unten bleiben sie zu hause
am besten so wie es gerade hört auch die
antwort hierher war schon extrem
schwierig weil eben umgestürzte bäume
die straßen unpassierbar machen und da
kann eben ein kurzer weg zur arbeit auch
wenn es nur ein paar kilometer sind zur
falle werden wenn vor einmal
umgestürzter baum liegt bekommt nicht
mehr weiter hinter einem die straße
eventuell auch noch durch regen oder
durch eine verspätung von schmelz und
regenwasser
unpassierbar wird plötzlich ist man
gefangen in dieser natur in diesen
gewalten die gerade wirken wenn sie
fahren müssten packen sie sich eine
notfallausrüstung indem sie warme decken
mitnehmen sie eine thermoskanne mit und
tanken sie das auto voll dass sie
eventuell die heizung laufen lassen
können das ist wirklich wichtig oder
noch besser eben zu hause zu bleiben
damit sie den rettungskräften die arbeit
so leicht wie möglich machen und eben
nicht auch noch zu einem notfall werden
wir hoffen sehr du stehst ganz alleine
dort auf dem brocken auf wii ds gönnen
würden das sind ein bisschen er jemanden
dabei hat der sich sehr unterstützt
außerdem kameramann aber ich nehme
anderen es ist wagt sich wirklich
derzeit kein mensch dort irgendwie in
den ich muss
wir sind um 10 uhr verabredet mit dem
leiter der bergwacht hier aus
wernigerode mit dem man gebäude früh
lange telefoniert und abgewägt ob es
verantwortbar ist dass wir hier
hochfahren wir haben gesagt wir machen
unser absoluter
berücksichtigung unserer eigenen
sicherung natürlich und sie nach oben
auf bisher geht es uns wirklich den
umstände sprechen hut weil wir eben auch
gut ausgerüstet und erfahren sind in
solchen situationen aber leute die jetzt
hierher kommen wollen da reicht es ja
das von oben knickt mit dem bein das
wird plötzlich nicht mehr mobil ist dass
die wolken hier oben auch die sicht
nehmen und dort die orientierung
verliert die retter hätten dann wenig
chancen ein in der rechtzeitig noch zu
finden und eben aus dieser wahl sind
geteilt in dieser funktion verbreitet
wir gehen also weiter vorne ist ein
reißverschluss wer ist eigentlich strom
und winddicht aber der wind pfeift hier
in meiner jacke rein dann droht da habe
ich fünf schichten post wolle merino und
kunstfaser
dem ich versucht warm zu halten das
funktioniert auch eine ganze weile ganz
gut aber eben nach einer halben stunde
warten auf retter wenn es eben zu einem
unglück kommt dann wäre auch hier bei
mir schluss deshalb wirklich mal ein
dringender appell auch von der bergwacht
bleiben sie zu hause konnten sie nicht
hier oben hin man kann viele reporter
hannes radweg dort im extrem einsatz auf
dem brocken wo ist natürlich ganz ganz
besonders stürmt aktuell aber im ganzen
land sind heftige stürme moment
unterwegs und für die nächsten stunden
und tage auch weiter angesagt